it's it's affecting my relationships
it's affecting my job Matthew I think
it's time you admit it to yourself you
have an addiction to internet
pornography okay so what kind of stuff
were you into why I need to know to help
your treatment
Japanese school girls mmm interesting
it's kind of Google image safe search
off or weep and I would pay I'll go to a
pay side premium
yeah what website ww
Dick's in comm it's just it's you know
that's what's mm-hmm what are you doing
I'm gonna take notes aren't you taking
notes with your pen this is out of ink
go on oh I was saying you were about to
give me your school's out Dixon calm
user name and password no I wasn't just
give it to me okay it's felt belt and
the password is uh is a toy box uh-huh
interesting hututu yeah well maybe as a
child you know you didn't get enough
toys or gifts have you ever kidding have
you ever considered that there weren't
enough toys there's toys so many toys
how long have you been a day i dick
addictive addicted to internet
pornography
yes that's good how long have you been
addicted to the internet pornography
probably since I was 18 18 18 nearly
legal who knew 18 plus 18 was 69 I'm
sorry
18 I think we should talk about some
treatments okay
well what do you suggest really quite
simple I think you need to pull yourself
up by your strap on one just about boot
straps you strap on some boot straps and
strap them on and grab them okay
mm-hm take it pick it on the take it off
visit get on the chin we won sorry I was
thinking of something else I was
thinking of male ejaculate this is
inappropriate you're right yeah you're
right I apologize thank you you just
need to reorganize your priorities Oh
your small Japanese priorities you know
what see this is the problem [ __ ] is I I
just wanted help summer soap is someone
glass this is not helping alright I came
in my pants and that's how time I picked
the wrong day to wear khakis
[Music]